[Music]
juan james not happy about what happened
to him on friday the denver broncos
releasing him
they will not be paying his salary that
was guaranteed for skill injury and cap
specifically injury happening on the job
he's released because of a non-football
injury he doesn't get paid and juwan
james says at nflpa if you're going to
advise all of us we need you to have our
backs on the other end of this and he's
a prime example of the guy who who did
what the union recommended that he do he
was working out at the facility union
says don't so he went on his own there
was
a workout program given to him by the
team the team was very careful to say
these are voluntary options and we are
not responsible for any injury that you
suffer away from the workplace there's
going to be a grievance because you're
talking about 10 million dollars you may
as well give it a try maybe you get
lucky i just can't imagine james being
successful chris against the the team
when it's as plain as day you get
injured at work you're covered you get
injured away from work you're not
covered and if you're going to be doing
the workout the team gave you
why not just show up at the team
facility and do it there i know well i
mean i think you know at base level he
brings up like a good point
i mean again if the organization that
you're a part of the union that you're a
part of is advising you to do something
that can financially hurt your life and
ruin you for
an injury
you would think
there is insurance for something like
that i mean that would be
i to me again not that i'm sitting here
and i'm johnny lawyer or anything like
that but that just seems common sense
you know when i when you read the tweet
and everything like that i was just like
yeah i mean duh i know i wish i would
have thought about that last week and
said that but yeah that that makes sense
and uh that's where i feel for juwan
james and that's where i tell all
players get back to the facility and do
your workouts there
and people around the league are
interpreting his tweet as an indication
that among his various options he will
explore pursuing
some type of action against the union
now
generally speaking it's very hard
to to hold a union responsible for
breaching what they call the duty of
fair representation it's an extremely
high bar but you know in this case and
i'm not i look i don't know how it plays
out all i know is the guy's out 10
million bucks
and if he can prove that that uh
he listened to the nflpa and they didn't
advise him of the potential risks that
he was incurring by working out on his
own that's a potential problem but he
also has an agent he also yeah that's
the thing the agents that's why the
agents are telling these guys show up
that's one of the reasons why and of all
the guys
of all the guys in the nfl who should
have been told you should be at the team
facility when you're working out he got
17 million for three games in 2019 he
opted out last year not that that should
be held against any player but nobody's
realistic yeah you're coming back after
sitting out all last year you got to
prove yourself you got to establish
yourself you're going to be working out
anyway work out in the team facility and
get the protection that goes along with
it your surgery is covered your rehab's
covered and you get your 10 million by
cutting him on friday he's on his own
for his rehab chris yeah he is
completely on his own no i mean mike
your point about first off if there's
been any player that should have been
there yeah it's players that are in his
boat exactly right oh we gave you a ton
of money and you've played three games
and then the other year you decided not
to play like i don't care it's a
business
you know yeah you said what you want
yeah no business is gonna be like oh
great you've taken 17 million from us
and done nothing oh yeah we'll give you
the benefit of the doubt and keep you
around for a while even though you're
hurt stin you're hurt now and you're
gonna steal another 10 million from us
right i mean come on what do you expect
the team to do at this point to me mike
like the big thing is for for that i'd
like to ask you
like
does he have any
real
like merit here as far as if he was to
bring this to the nflpa and be like
listen you didn't warn me
of this i wasn't aware of this
circumstance here and would he be able
to then you know sue the nflpa or get
money out of them for for this whole
situation that's a nuance i've never had
the occasion to research that is a fancy
way of saying i have no idea but that's
how you find out that's how you get an
idea you research how other similar
cases out there cases with similar facts
how those have been handled but the
argument would be if you're the lawyer
representing juwan james the union
recommended that you not be present for
these workouts the union didn't tell
juwan james oh by the way if you work
out on your own and you get injured
here's all the things you're going to
lose they didn't tell him that when he
made his decision and and i'm telling
you if it comes to that
the union is going to pin it on the
agent saying this is where the agent
needed to intervene
and be aware of his situation and be
aware of the union and advise him yeah
and advise him
on what he had to do so i think the
agent is in a more delicate spot here
than the union if the agent didn't say
to juwan james hey juwan before you go
down to planet fitness with your sheet
of paper from the strength coach with
all the different exercises you're
supposed to do or that they recommend
that you do or the voluntary options
whatever language the broncos use so
they're not on the hook before but you
know before you do that
you got some reasons like maybe 10
million of them plus
to just
go to the facility and tell the nfl pa
thanks but no thanks on this one i got
to take care of myself and my family
you're it's interesting you're i mean to
me i mean i didn't really but you're
right i mean it it kind of does fall
back on the agent i mean the agent like
certifies right they're certified
through the union to work that way
so yeah i would think that maybe you're
right sorry excuse me
i'm hiccuping here and burping at the
same time my coffee thank you good
morning everybody thank you uh thank you
but yeah that's an interesting angle
that you're right i think is a little
more on the agent than i maybe thought
of earlier
and i think that
that's where whoever's advising juwan
james needs to tread lightly and and i
think that what he needs at this point
is somebody completely disconnected
from anyone who's had any involvement
with him right whatsoever you need a
completely objective neutral voice who
can identify the various
responsibilities and advise you on what
to do because the agent
may say
uh you know what it's an uphill climb
against the union let's not go down that
path recognizing that if he does the
union's going to turn back around and
say it's on the agent and oh by the way
we have the power to discipline the
agent if we want to do so maybe we maybe
we choose to discipline the agent for
not telling juwan james that it was in
his best interest to not
to not listen to us
to ignore our recommendation that he's
one of the ones that should be present
and working out so i really do think for
his own best interest and to the extent
that there is someone out there who has
responsibility for this guy being out 10
million bucks he needs to find somebody
completely disconnected completely
neutral completely objective who can
advise him on his rights and uh i i that
that's the advice i'd give to anyone in
this situation get someone who can tell
you where you need to go for the
compensation that you deserve i sound
like a 1 800 call the lawyers but but
that's true you know nobody likes
lawyers until they need one he needs a
good one to help him navigate his way
through this because it sounds like
someone may be responsible for that 10
million yeah i know i'm i am gonna be
like kind of uh just interested to see
how he
where he takes this from here on out i
am and just to continue to kind of gauge
like the nfl pa and their stance on this
as we go forward and everything like
that but uh yeah crazy situation i feel
for juwan james uh as we have talked
about but
man yeah i just it's it's one where i
think they're ill-advised i do and we'll
see where it goes from here
by the way the union says 38 percent of
players have shown up so far for
offseason workouts now
i'm trying to get more information as to
where that includes all the rookies who
have been there because it's been
virtually all rookies but phase two
starts today it's on field coaching it's
not otas but it's it's not just working
out we'll see how many guys show up for
that and then the otas start next week
so uh uh look the juwan james situation
is uh the warning shot for the other
players at a minimum talk to your agents
look at your contract and understand the
risks you're taking if you continue to
work out away from the facility
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports